mike scioscia the angels manager so kind
to call in from Arizona I know I've got
you for like five minutes things too the
great Tim me but I might good to have
you on how are you doing I'm so great
it's better for talking to you it's been
a long time it's been a while and I know
you're doing well and I know rich is
doing well and we're in Goodyear Arizona
and could be better I'm so glad to hear
it and it's been a long time since we
had the six and fourteen seasons
together so they entered in that
incredible World Series run so thrilled
to have you join me I really appreciate
it okay good tell me about Shohei Otani
what is it like managing this to a
thread well right now we're obviously
have a lot on our plate your pitch he's
getting his swing where needs and and
get him get him at bats to get him ready
to swing during the season so right now
we're not sure how many I passed it's
going up to over this course of the
season but we're definitely going to DHM
one way of opportunities to and we need
we go out there on the mound because he
has an electric arm so this guy's a
definitely a unique talent you're not
used to having this much attention I
don't think because I mean I've been
hearing that there's twenty thirty guys
from the Japanese media following
wherever he goes yeah there's uh there's
at least that many guys but it's no
problem they're really they don't
interfere with or workout maybe on a
personal level takes me an extra five or
six minutes a day which is no big deal
and Shohei is very accessible but he's
as you said to meet is coordinating this
and they made it very functional and
seamless to where think he can do his
interviews and not miss a beat on the
field what do you think will be the most
difficult transition for him I mean I
know the mound is somewhat different
when the Japanese League yes
none of the mound baseballs a little bit
different the skin of the ball and
Japanese baseball is a little bit
different than our baseballs and he's
he's getting acclimated with that he
started throwing our baseballs a while
ago when he was over Japan so he's
getting acclimated and
there's a little difference in the
mouths outside of that it's baseball you
know you've got to square it up when
it's in the zone and and then try to
miss fats when you're pitching and how
do you think you're gonna use him
because it is obviously it's very
different to have a pitcher
I guess Madison Baumgardner is the only
one that you can make any kind of
reference to but how would you use him
so that you keep him fresh and keep his
arm a little bit healthier yeah there's
no doubt that this there's gonna be a
schedule of when he's available I think
if we're if he's pitching it happens
being against a national in club well
that's easy he'll hit on those days if
he's uh you know if he's got if we just
pitched a day and in his day to recovery
probably won't be available a D H and
maybe the day he throws his bullpen
there'll be some days where he's
restricted but outside of that he'll be
he'll be available to D H and come off
our bench if we need it and whatever we
need you know I think the biggest
challenge for him also like and this
will be interesting to see how this
happens it again is to keep him healthy
just because you don't see that many
players who are sharing this transition
between they you know the hitting and
the pitching no doubt just for the
pitching side I think a lot of Japanese
pitchers that have come over to the
United States have had a little problem
with stamina they've been banked up
banged up and and they've missed some
time I think that our GM Billy Epler has
done a tremendous job and has kind of
worked out a six-man rotation to get to
get guys the rest and hopefully keep
these guys not only fresh but effective
so I think that hopefully I mean we'll
talk all through the season you know
about it but hopefully he'll he'll
overcome those hurdles and go out there
and get his starts and contribute both
on the mound in at the plate is he on a
pitch count not so much a pitch count
right now he stepped up until I get
stepped up yes but he's thrown anywhere
from 115 to 125 pitches and games over
Japan so there's the ones we get him
stepped up there won't be a pitch count
but there certainly with a six-man
rotation it'll be much closer to the
rotation that he pitched in in Japan
then coming over here your typical US
rotation of five guys and what's the
plan when he's not pitching
well when he's not pitching if there's
were if it's right after he pitching
these recovery day then he probably
won't be available with D H will read
him every day to see what he feels like
he's recover from pitching to winning go
out there swinging a bat and see if he's
going to be you know an option on that
given day but more so he's got he's got
time in between two throws bullpen one
or two bullpens whatever he's
comfortable doing lifts his weights
recover get strong for his next start so
there's a lot of work involved trying to
do people age both on the pitch than the
offensive end Mike I so appreciate your
time thank you for calling it I know I
promised him I would keep you on the
phone for a couple minutes because you
might be in a van full of managers and
coaches I want to let you go Susie thank
you and say hi to rich good talking to
you I will do that thank you Mike
Scioscia joining us the Angels manager
here on the Rich Eisen show so Rich
Eisen show